[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROK ZORKO: I'm Rok Zorko.
I am the VP of products.
When we started, it
was just eight of us.
Everything was sketched
on a whiteboard
and then built very quickly.
In the first six months, I think
we built seven or eight apps.
And the last one, Talking
Tom, was then a global hit.
IZA LOGIN: Currently,
we have more than 2.5
billion downloads, more than
250 million monthly users
only on Talking Tom
and Friends franchise,
and we are all thrilled
to continue this way.
ROK ZORKO: We've seen Android
become our majority platform.
When we launched My Talking
Tom in November 2013,
the initial numbers were 50/50.
So 50% of users and downloads
came from Android and 50
from other platforms.
Now, the split is 70/30.
So 70% Android, 30%
other platforms,
but we use the same
cross promotion.
We use the same
marketing, so this just
means that Android has grown.
So Outfit7's launch
strategy on the latest games
has always been all
platforms at the same time,
and the main reason for that is
the effect that you can achieve
is the biggest,
and we don't really
want any of our
users to be unhappy.
MARKO STAMCAR: We launched
My Talking Angela back
in December.
We first did stage
rollout in Google Play,
and then after
everything was ready,
we went 100% on all platforms.
And in about a week, I think
we got 10 million downloads.
So that was a huge success and
recognition for all our teams,
from product to marketing.
ROK ZORKO: When we were
just doing paid apps,
and now we're doing freemium
apps within our purchases
from 2013 and 2014, the revenue
growth was more than 1,000%.
So I think we chose the right
strategy going freemium.
When we built our first app,
the only app provider in there
was AdMob It's still one of our
most important ad providers.
We didn't actually expected that
we would be earning as much.
Our most successful
apps at the moment all
have a lot of mini
games in it, and we
decided that the best way to
get engagement on a new level
was to put in Google Play
services leaderboards,
and that really helps
competition in a healthy way.
I think the main reason why
our downloads keep growing ever
faster is because we were always
effective at cross promotion.
We always say internally
that 50% of our business
is building great
apps and games,
and the other 50% is making
sure that people notice them.
MARKO STAMCAR: When we
became successful in apps,
we wanted Outfit7 to become
more than just an app company.
We wanted to become an
entertainment company.
So we started building
up our YouTube Channel,
and now we have
millions of subscribers
and 1.4 billion viewers.
And we just recently have been
accepted into the YouTube Kids
app.
IZA LOGIN: Google play a
big role because in certain
territories, without
Google, we cannot imagine
our distribution, and it's
really nice to see users
worldwide playing with
our apps and having fun.